♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
Tomorrow is Election Day,
which means President Biden's
impeachment trial, I guess,
starts on Wednesday.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump
is reportedly planning
to formally announce
his presidential campaign
on November 14th.
No word yet on his choice
for V.P.
or First Lady.
[ Laughter ]
Former President Barack Obama
and Donald Trump
held separate rallies over
the weekend in Pennsylvania.
Obama campaigned
for John Fetterman,
and Trump campaigned
for 2024.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee Chair
Sean Patrick Maloney said
in an interview yesterday
that Democrats will maintain
control of Congress and added,
"We're not perfect,
but we are responsible adults
who didn't attack the Capitol."
Not exactly a high bar.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats are like the stepdad
of political parties.
They may be lame,
but at least they're not the guy
who walked out on you.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, I'm here!"
Yesterday was the end of
daylight savings time,
in case you were wondering
why these all feel
more like 1:30 in the morning
jokes.
[ Light laughter ]
The New York City marathon
was held yesterday,
and Kenyan runner Evans Chebet
was the men's champion
with a time of 2 hours,
8 minutes, and 41 seconds.
2 hours, 8 minutes,
and 41 seconds --
the fastest anyone has ever
gotten from Staten Island
to Central Park.
[ Laughter ]
At a rally in Pennsylvania
over the weekend,
former president Trump
called Florida governor
Ron DeSantis, quote,
"Ron DeSanctimonious."
Has anyone ever been worse at
coming up with nicknames?
Imagine Trump in "Top Gun."
People, people,
I know we all love Maverick,
but I think I got one
that beats it.
Are you ready?
Everybody ready?
"Airplane Guy."
That's right,
former President Trump
referred to Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
as Ron DeSanctimonious,
which is a risky move for Trump
because that's six syllables.
[ Laughter ]
A J.C. Penney location in
Pennsylvania temporarily closed
last week after a deer wandered
into the store.
Even crazier, a couple weeks
ago, a shopper wandered in.
[ Laughter ]
He's asking what aisle
stuff's in.
Over 50 students in El Paso,
Texas,
may have to retake the S.A.T.
after their answer sheets
flew out of a UPS truck
and were either lost
or destroyed.
The students are calling
the incident disheartening,
regrettable, disconcerting,
or irksome.
[ Laughter ]
Astronomers predict that
a total lunar eclipse
will occur tomorrow.
So, if you look outside
and the moon turns red,
Don't worry, it just means
Dr. Oz won his Senate race.
[ Light laughter ]
That's what the prophecy
foretold.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the makers of
Miller Lite this week
will offer a Christmas tree
keg stand.
And if you're wondering
what Santa's bringing you --
AA pamphlets.
♪♪
Yesterday was Election Day
and "Late Night"
is now projecting
the Democrats will pick up
at least one seat
at Thanksgiving dinner.
[ Laughter ]
In an interview last night
with NBC News,
South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham said,
"Hats off to the Democrats
for performing well
in swing districts."
Oh, yeah, hats way off!
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Senator
Raphael Warnock
and Republican challenger
Herschel Walker
are set to head to a runoff
on December 6th
to decide Georgia's Senate race.
And, if you think Georgia's
election process is confusing,
imagine trying to explain it
to Herschel Walker.
[ Laughter ]
Pennsylvania Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman
defeated Republican candidate
Dr. Mehmet Oz yesterday...
[ Cheering and applause ]
...in the state Senate race.
Oz says he's just happy
he doesn't have to pretend
to root for the
Philadelphia Steelers anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Democrat Maxwell Frost yesterday
became the first member
of Generation Z elected
to Congress,
while Chuck Grassley recorded
another win
for Generation Zzz!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Mumbling ]
[ Laughter ]
Texas Senator Ted Cruz
was booed this week at the
Houston Astros World Series
Championship Parade.
As well as the bank,
the grocery store,
[ Laughter ]
his office,
[ Applause ]
and at his house.
All in all, a pretty average
week for Ted Cruz.
[ Laughter and applause ]
President Biden
and former
President Barack Obama
posted a video
on Twitter this week
[ Laughter ]
reminding people to vote.
You know, it's nice to see
they're still friends.
The only way we're getting video
of Trump and Pence together is
if Maury springs it on them.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Maryland yesterday became
the 20th state
to legalize marijuana,
which means that,
for the first time ever,
there's something to do
in Maryland.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Former President Trump voted
in yesterday's midterm elections
in Florida, then,
because he can't help himself,
took a bunch of ballots back
to Mar-A-Lago.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a Brooklyn man
who was on the run
from fraud charges
was arrested recently in Florida
after the federal agent
who signed his arrest warrant
spotted him
at a Disney theme park.
[ Laughter ]
Huh!
It's a small world.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Always...end...with....
a dad joke.
♪♪
President Biden spoke today at
a DNC event to thank staffers
and volunteers.
Okay, but you know
who you really
need to be thanking, right?
I mean, the way his endorsements
performed,
this man needs a fruit basket,
which would be a solid burn,
because he doesn't eat fruit.
[ Laughter ]
Following Democrats'
surprisingly strong performance
in the midterms, White House
chief of staff Ron Klain
tweeted yesterday,
"Never underestimate how much
Team Biden is underestimated."
[ Laughter ]
And wow, what a rallying cry.
That's like if Coach Taylor
said, "Clear eyes,
full hearts, everyone thinks
we're going to lose.
But guess what.
We're not going to lose
by as much as everyone thought
and we're going to call
that a win.
Go get 'em."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump's
daughter Tiffany is reportedly
worried that Tropical Storm
Nicole will ruin
her wedding this weekend
at Mar-a-Lago.
Though if I were her,
I'd be more worried about
this tropical depression.
[ Laughter ]
Just moping around, complaining
about the midterms, jumping in
front to catch the bouquet,
and yelling, "This means
I'm the nominee in 2024."
[ Laughter ]
Allies of former President Trump
are reportedly telling him
to delay his planned 2024
campaign announcement,
so now he has to come up with
a new explanation
for what his big announcement
was.
"Uh, we're launching Trump brand
hard seltzer."
[ Laughter ]
"That was always the plan
and not something
we just threw together."
Pennsylvania Republican Senate
candidate Dr. Mehmet Oz conceded
yesterday in a phone call
to Lieutenant Governor
John Fetterman.
Fetterman knew it was him
because it was not
a Pennsylvania number.
[ Laughter ]
Ex-Trump organization CFO Allen
Weisselberg recently testified
that former President Trump
inflated the value of
his Trump Tower apartment
by $200 million,
which he did by claiming
it was a two-bedroom.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
It's a joke about New York City
real estate, but...
[ Laughter ]
I'll explain
during the commercial.
[ Laughter ]
A T-Rex dinosaur skull will go
up for auction next month and is
expected to sell for 20 million
of Nic Cage's dollars.
[ Laughter ]
A professional archer in Denmark
recently broke a Guinness
world record by shooting
seven arrows through a keyhole.
Great for him, terrible for
his nosy neighbor.
[ Laughter ]
Is that a two-bedroom?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Phew.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, organizers of the
Westminster Kennel Club Dog Show
have announced that next year's
event will be moved
from Madison Square Garden
to Billie Jean King National
Tennis Center in Queens.
What could possibly go wrong?
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
♪♪